le président américain joe biden a
annoncé hier soir que le chef d'al qaïda
ayman al zawahiri a été tué en fin de
semaine lors d'une frappe américaine à
kaboul en afghanistan
celui ci avait participé à la
coordination des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 pour dresser le portrait
de cette organisation terroriste avec
nous sami a uni les politicologues il
est professeur émérite à l'école de
politique appliquée de l'université de
sherbrooke et directoire de directeur de
l'observatoire sur le moyen orient et
l'afrique du nord à l'uqam sami aoun
bonsoir qu on soit à ayman al zawahiri
c'était l'un des terroristes les plus
recherchés de la planète les états unis
avaient mis 25 mille dollars là comme
récompense en échange d'informations qui
permettrait de mener à sa capture à quel
point ils représentaient une menace mais
surtout à quel point qu al qaïda est
encore une organisation qui représente
un danger pour l'occident
vous avez bien raison de souligner que
ayman zawahiri était une personnalité
telle et qui a été éclipsée soit par le
charisme de oussama ben laden soit aussi
malgré qu'il est un grand organisateur
un grand stratège aussi idiots log assez
bien articulé sauf que il n'avait pas
vraiment une emprise sur al quaida de la
sorte que les gens lui payer une loyauté
reconnaissant sa légitimité même pas
nécessairement vraiment de le suivre
c'est pourquoi lui peut-être dans son
bénéfice et l'a fait que al qaïda n'est
plus une organisation pyramidale
mais elle est devenue de plus en plus
une organisation plutôt les otites
plutôt dans les réseaux et les cellules
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on a
plusieurs franchises de al qaeda même si
lui il tenait la maison mère mais
pratiquement al qaeda est plus une
menace diffuse donc une france
des succursales finalement d'al qaïda le
fait que ce soit diffus que finalement
la menace soit répartie est ce que c'est
une menace qui devient moindre pour
l'occident
en quelque sorte oui il a fait quelques
éclats c'est tellement on n'oublie pas
toulouse on oublie pas charlie hebdo à
paris on n'oublie pas certainement le 11
septembre 2001 n'ont plus les
assassinats à londres sauf si on
remarque bien on voit que l'islamisme
radical en général ils passent dans une
crise doctrinale et idiot logique et
même si vous ne marquez bien dans les
foyers de troubles au moyen-orient en
syrie ou en irak ou ailleurs on voit que
cette mouvance al qaïda elle presque sur
la défensive sinon elle bat en retraite
et elle a été devancée plutôt bardèche
où l'état islamique qui avec elle il y a
une grande divergence idéologique
l'état islamique voulait construire un
état et territoriale tandis que al qaïda
voulait garder ce que l avoir et les
hadji a toujours pensé contre l'ennemi
local c'est-à-dire les régimes qui a ra
musulmans qu'ils considèrent comme
suppôt de l'occident et qui sont et qui
sont entrain de plomb voir info islam où
ils sont anti islam est aussi l'occident
coloniales et impérialistes qui est
l'ennemi lointain en ce sens oui il ya
toujours une menace de ce côté et comme
de l'autre bon vous parlez de l'état
islamique je reviens à un instant à al
qaïda qu'est ce que ça nous révèle sur
les liens entre les talibans en
afghanistan et al qaïda le fait que le
numéro un est été abattu à kaboul
c'est vrai aussi c'est que il y a dans
les talibans plusieurs poches de
décision plusieurs centres des décisions
anoci de bonne foi les négociateurs des
talibans ont signé l'entente dedans avec
les américains et il ne savait pas qu
est-ce que l'ale radical et militante et
combatif chez eux est en train de
planifier pour réhabiliter et ray est
belle al qaeda alors si c'est de bonne
foi ce serait un problème à l'intérieur
des talibans mais si c'est mais plutôt
de mauvaise foi donc on comprend que les
talibans et al qaeda sont pratiquement
de la même mouvance islamiste radicale
et qui sont des frères rivaux mais pas
nécessairement ennemis mais en ce sens
al quaida que monsieur al zaouahri vient
des grottes et des caves et qu'il voit
et qu'on le voit dernièrement dans
peut-être le quartier le plus huppé de
kaboul le quartier diplomatique et qu'il
soit fauché par l'armement à médical le
plus sophistiqué certainement ici ness
désiré soit les talibans n'ont pas un
projet de société et ils ne veulent pas
vraiment construire un état et un
développement en afghanistan ils veulent
garder leur pays et comme plutôt une
place de règlements de comptes et 1 a
pris un air un refuge pour les éléments
les plus radicaux rigaud liste des
terroristes de l'islam oui à voir si ça
va être à nouveau un sanctuaire pour les
terroristes sami aoun je vous remercie
beaucoup
nous ont dit au revoir